when we began this Nizar in Yemen where
Houthi rebels have released hundreds of
Saudi UAE fighters as a gesture of
goodwill in the hope it will lead to a
larger exchange of prisoners now this
comes a day after hootie commander
showed video footage that they claimed
showed the capture of thousands of saudi
back faces that happens June what hootie
see was a wire in assault inside Saudi
Arabia cost to the city of Natron near
the saudi yemen border and in the past
few hours the Red Cross confirmed it has
overseen the release and transfer of 290
prisoners even though hootie forces say
they've released 350 detainees while PT
say the release was undertaken as a show
of sincerity to their parts of the
Swedish ceasefire agreements we
reiterate our commitment to a prisoner
swap deal that has not changed it is
today as it was and we are prepared and
willing to execute an all inclusive swap
deal whether they are Yemenis or other
nationalities to prove our veracity we
have initiated an unconditional release
of 350 prisoners from the other side we
have called on the United Nations to
pressure the coalition to reciprocate
this initiative falls within the Swedish
agreement and today we are going to
execute and honor this agreement under
the plans and knowledge of the United
Nations and the Swedish agreement
mohamed al ahzab has more from a Sunnah
Hafiz by releasing and conditionally
those prisoners of war want to send a
message to the wall that they are
willing to continue their obligations
toward the peace agreement of Sweden and
also that these prisoners are for what
being released today among them forty
prisoners of war who have survived the
Saudi attack on the detention center and
the mass also they are preparing to
release three prisoners of four who are
from the Saudi nationalities but they
have to coordinate with the
International Red Cross committee they
have also the during the presser
condemned what
describe the Saudi recruitment of
children in there and the defense of
their southern Dada they said that they
have recruited children with the age of
13 and 16 years old so they are also
they are crawling all day and the world
during the pressure that there are had
the deaths of those who have been killed
during their latest operations there are
they are laying there and the
international community and the
International Red Cross haven't been
able to reach those who have been killed
as they are laying on the ground where
the oppression has taken place well
let's get more on this nicely Beck - is
the spokeswoman for the International
Committee of the Red Cross and joins us
now by Skype from Aden and that's the
your organization help to oversee this
prisoner release what more can you tell
us about that
yes today the International Committee of
the Red Cross / so the release of 290
detainees that were held in that among
Central Prison and so now our role in in
this particular release was to first
conduct pre-departure interviews with
all the detainees to verify their
identities and also to check with them
if they have any concerns where they
would like to go when they are released
so that we can also help with with with
a transfer we provided monetary monetary
incentives to for their transfer we also
had medical staff on-site as per all our
releases there's always a medical staff
on-site that attracts the health of HTE
is and if anybody needs special measures
to be transferred we also work with the
authorities to do that - eme detainees
were actually transferred to their areas
of origin through the way you may read
Crescent Society ambulances I'm sorry to
cut you off where were you transferred
in the - are you transferring them to
Saudi Arabia where these Saudi prisoners
today the 290 detainees were all Yemenis
they were all Yemenis okay now these are
these are prisoners which were taken by
the hisses they have called on Saudi
Arabia to to mimic their gesture to
release prisoners that are being held by
their size has your organization been
asked to intervene releasing prisoners
held by Saudi the saudi side we of
course welcome any requests for the
International Committee of the Red Cross
to to be part in any release operation
so we definitely hope that other sides
will take this initiative and request
the International Committee of the Red
Cross to partake in a release operation
now the the some discrepancy with the
numbers here the the Houthis are saying
they've released 350 your this the Red
Cross have said it's only Bitsey 90 I do
you account for the discrepancy between
the two figures yes of course we can
account for the numbers that were
released today in in our presence but
there may be and there may have been the
thing is that were released at another
time without the facilitation of the Red
Cross
so this discrepancy perhaps comes from
that and and in terms of your working on
the grounds you're working in Yemen we
see things progressing on a military and
the military side of it but certainly
the focus is now turning to to bring an
end to this conflict are you hopeful
that with this gesture by the WHO T
sides are you hopeful that this may
leads to two more talks or two more
prisoner exchanges of course we are very
we hope this is definitely our hope that
this release which of course has brought
a lot of relief to the families who have
been suffering you know missing their
loved ones or not doing where they are
you know the people who are released a
day where fathers sons brothers of
course we hope to see more initiatives
in the future bigger numbers from all
sides and as the International Committee
of the Red Cross
we are always ready to act as a neutral
facilitator just as we did today in any
future release operations so definitely
we are hopeful and we also hope that
this release we've contributes to the
revival of the Stockholm agreement and
that more releases happen in the future
okay Nathalie Beck - speaking to us from
Aden in Yemen thank you very much indeed